après 27 années passées dans l'industrie
béatrice pira souhaite mettre à profit
de voisins-le-bretonneux ses compétences
de gestion de projet et d'équipé
c'est une première campagne pour cette
cinquantenaire ça demande beaucoup
d'énergie pour mobiliser non seulement
les colistiers mais aussi la population
car je ne suis pas connu aujourd'hui
donc il faut que je fasse ma place dans
la ville lors de sa réunion publique
béatrice pierrât a exposé son programme
aux habitants parmi ses propositions un
plan vélo ou encore la création d'une
maison du savoir partagé afin de
favoriser les échanges
intergénérationnels
il y a beaucoup de compétences dans la
ville notamment chez nos retraités et
nous souhaitons partager ses compétences
ses expériences dans une maison que nous
avons appelé aujourd'hui maison du
savoir partagé pour permettre aux plus
jeunes ou moins jeunes de profiter de
cette expérience de ses compétences
disponibles et on pouvoir ainsi avancé
la candidate est accompagné par jean h
élu d'opposition et anciennement tête de
liste pour voisins avec vous lors des
élections municipales en 2014
je considérais que moi je le devais
passer le témoin mais ne pas déserter et
donc j'ai voulu qu'ils aient une liste
qui piloté par dès janvier nouveau mais
qui se retrouvent sur des valeurs
communes et nous avons construit un
programme sur trois piliers un premier
pilier sur les transition écologique et
énergétique à deuxième pilier sur la
démocratie participative et a3 et payée
sur la solidarité la prochaine réunion
publique se déroule samedi 7 mars de 16h
à 17h30 à la maison du mes rentes et de
voisins le bretonneux